parts of the southeast are expecting
another day of record-breaking heat at
least 48 children have died this year
from being left in hot cars that's close
to matching last year's record number
the most recent death happened on
Tuesday in Phoenix where a four month
old was left inside a van on a 91 degree
day Kris Van Cleave is in Washington
Chris why does this keep happening and
how do we stop it well Anthony the
technology in this car may be part of
the solution but you know kids are more
susceptible to heat stroke so that's
part of the problem the vast majority of
the time 84% of these cases it's purely
accidental the parent either forgets the
child is in the car or the kid got into
the car without the parents knowing now
the obvious question how does a parent
forget their child is in the car mental
health experts say it's complicated
often there's a change in routine
coupled with how our brains are wired
I remember apologizing to her Wes and
Dawn Peabody's two-year-old daughter
Maya died after she was mistakenly left
in the back of West's car outside their
Phoenix area home I didn't know she was
in the car until I saw her in the car
and that was just I don't have words for
what that was like it was a Saturday
dawn usually drove Maya but the routine
changed family was in town and Wes
forgot she was in the back seat the
knee-jerk reaction is to blame the
parent dr. David diamond is a
psychologist and a leading researcher in
this field we have kind of a brain
autopilot system that allows us to go
from point A to point B without thinking
about it and it actually suppresses our
awareness that the child is in the car
and what is so tragic is that they think
they've actually gone to the right
location that the child has been dropped
off at daycare since 1990 kids were
unintentionally left behind in nearly
60% of these cases another 1 in 4
involved a child getting into the car on
their own I didn't remember that she had
gone home with us and told dad asked
where she was at and then you go outside
and you see her in the car and it was
years later that memory is still
devastating the Peabody's are now urging
calm
to pass a bill requiring car makers to
install a backseat warning system a
system like the one Hyundai is rolling
out but as an optional feature it
includes a chime and dashboard message
to check the backseat if the driver
locks the car and walks away the horn
goes off and the car sends a push alert
to the owners phone just last month
automakers agreed to voluntarily make
some form of backseat alert standard in
cars by 2025 I think we're gonna say
watch Republican senator Roger wicker is
sponsoring a bill to require the alerts
but he supports the voluntary agreement
this is a quicker and better solution
and lives are going to be saved because
of it how confident are you in the
automakers to hit the deadline they
promised to make I'm very confident but
safety advocates worry there's no set
standard and no binding requirement we
want to make sure that this is an
enforceable rule something that they
have to be sure it's the complete system
both an alert and a notification for the
Peabody's talking about Maya a silly
toddler with a habit of running up and
hugging people is a way to warn parents
this tragedy can happen to anyone
first hi kiddos tell them you love them
but every parent every time needs to
open that back door open that back door
make sure you don't have precious cargo
back there now Hyundai is going to make
part of this system standard in all of
its cars the dashboard and the chime but
that second level the horn and the push
alert that's only available in certain
options if you don't have a car with
these systems experts say there are a
couple of simple things you can do keep
something like teddy bear or a kid's toy
up front with you and put something in
the back seat of yours that you'll need
like maybe your shoe or your briefcase
gaile that is really good advice cups
Van Cleave I always think put your purse
back there
thank you it's nice to see guys a
Peabody's still together because that I
thought it immediately it splits
families apart and I don't understand
why it can't be a mandatory it shouldn't
be an option it should be a mandatory
thing that's in cars we have the
technology to do it yes sometimes it's
expensive though and you got to give
people the option whether they want to
go
whatever the clock yeah but it's
certainly it literally could say like
yes yes it could